all right guys
what's up bang bang lunch money time
well she's trying to get rich russell
she's trying to get a lunch money right
i'm here with paulina
she's not here actually she's somewhere
else i'm not going to say where
undisclosed location she has left me
alone for a whole week
wait i don't know there's going to be
some craziness happening
don't forget that launchpad is now
sponsored by block five block by has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on the crypto exchange
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
or you can't earn up to 8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account go get a
account
blockfy.com blockfy.com what's up
what are the topics today first one
jack ma's ant group has just pulled off
the
biggest stock market listing in history
the
biggest the tech company behind china's
largest online payments platform priced
its dual listing on the hong kong stock
exchange
and shanghai star market at 80 hung
dollars or
cents and 10.13
whatever cents per share respectively is
the
largest ipo in history
what's crazy is that most people in the
us don't even know about ant group
yeah they they own a lot right well no
it's just people in the united states
don't know
they just don't know you know maybe
they've heard of like alibaba maybe
they've heard of wechat
maybe they've heard of some of that
stuff but group and financial
but amp financial is affiliated with
alibaba
of course but it's just like aunt group
the company right they just they just
are unaware of it it's kind of like a
berkshire hathaway you may know some of
the underlying products
or companies um but everyone in the us
for the most part or most people
are paying attention know about
berkshire hathaway right
in in the united states though the the
parent company ant
group is not as well known ant is one of
the biggest technology firms in the
world
and the biggest online payments platform
in china the app has established its
presence in every aspect of financial
life in china
i like your background by the way
namaste
all right i don't namaste but let's go
next topic
all right well that was cool i thought
um
okay so dunkin donuts is
america ronaldo duncan what yeah
duncan brands the parent company of
duncan in baskin robbins
is in preliminary discussions to be
acquired by a private equity
backed firm called inspired inspire
brands
i love it i had the ceo come on the
podcast
that the founding ceo oh he came on
he of duncan rant scaled it around the
world yeah
he's uh very experienced is a nice way
to put
he's a little bit older he no longer is
operational at the company
um but he uh was a wealth of knowledge i
mean the guy
it was so obvious that he knew what he
was doing when it came to business
uh because he had just done it for you
know literally decades and decades
and a lot of people might forget but
duncan was actually private back in 2005
and it went public in 2011 so now it's
going to go
back under private ownership inspire
would purchase duncan brands at 106.50
per share that would make the deal worth
roughly 8.8 billion this is a massive
deal if it goes through
america runs on duncan yep
i hope nobody's trying to buy starbucks
because starbucks you know they just
said i don't want to say it
did you get starbucks this morning i did
i had all kinds of weird orders that i
had to go get today
for those of you that don't know my
brother is sitting right here next to me
so i'm not alone
i'm not going to show him on camera
because he said he's a star we can't
feed his ego like that but
he sent me his starbucks order when i
went this morning and he said give me
black hot coffee i was like
didn't know i was living with a
psychopath go ahead
okay apple yes for those paying
attention at home she left me alone
and now i got friends here go ahead
apple is boosting its wearables business
um it's planning to launch new airpods
in airport
airpods pro as soon as early this is
there's a typo in this story
as soon as early oh as soon as early
next year i see okay
it's a move that could help apple
continue to boost its wearables home and
accessories business
which reported 6.45 billion in revenue
last quarter
up more than 16 percent from a year
earlier
and the segment includes air pods apple
watch apple tv accessories like chargers
and cases and stuff like that
apple's a healthcare company and apple
is going to be
a continued purveyor of data driven from
hardware and software their whole that's
their whole model they're going to lock
you into the ecosystem they're going to
continue to upgrade the hardware and
software they're going to get you to buy
more and more
try to expand the lifetime value of the
customer uh and they're also going to
then push into more and more services so
as they get
more pervasive with the hardware and
software then they get more data on you
when they get more data they can provide
better services when they provide better
services they get you to pay more money
uh and eventually they're going to move
from kind of one-off sales of hardware
or software
so they're going to get you on
subscriptions and so i think they're
very envious
of things like amazon prime and it
wouldn't surprise me at all
if whether it was uh the music uh
streaming
um or other types of uh subscriptions
those will eventually be replicated with
things
around healthcare and other new devices
in terms of the air pods i find myself
not using my air pods as much because
i'm not commuting
do we think that that at all had any
sort of impact on apple
i have no clue about sales of airpods i
still use my airpods every day
really yeah to when i go to the gym
or on a walk well i got these massive
headphones guys they're awesome so i
don't use air pods anymore
but you don't use those in the gym no
yeah cause you look ready okay um
next facebook announced on monday the
launch of
cloud gaming on his on its desktop
website and android app but said it's
unable to bring the games to ios
due to apple's arbitrary policies
do you want to remind us of apple's uh
stuff
apple's just not everyone's best friend
right now a lot of people not very happy
with apple
but apple's just gonna do what they do
until
they get hit with the anti-trust suit
which i'm
assuming is uh being dialed up but we'll
see
well we'll see i can't believe like
facebook's calling them out on it
of course riot games called them out on
it right but now facebook that's kind of
a big deal well stop preventing them
from getting their cloud games onto
apple devices
what if i want to play the cloud games
you got to get on desktop
next tesla will begin shipping made in
china electric
cars to europe on tuesday according to
chinese media reports
about seven thousand model threes made
at the shanghai
gigafactory are set to arrive in belgium
at the end of next month
with planned deliveries to countries
including germany france italy the
netherlands portugal switzerland
and sweden um so this is interesting
because um
it says that because of support of
government policies and less costly
technology
uh analysts predict that europe and
china the largest auto market in the
world
will see significant growth in electric
vehicle sales
in the coming years everyone said elon
couldn't do it they said he couldn't get
cars cranking out of uh the china
factory
they said he couldn't build the cars he
said he couldn't sell the cars
they said he couldn't build a
multi-billion dollar business everything
they've said this man has done
so guess what stop betting against elon
musk that's all i'm gonna say
although the idiot the one of the
greatest inventors slash
entrepreneurs of our lifetime is just
executing
he's executing you can't stop somebody
who's intelligent and can execute
and he's proven that so stop stop stop
trying to stop him
if you trying to stop elon musk he's
going to stop you okay
important side note last week chinese
regulators announced that tesla was
recalling up to 48
442 of its u.s made model s and model x
cars
that were sold to customers in china due
to potentially faulty and unsafe
front and rear suspensions
tesla's the safest car on the road
i don't even own a tesla i don't know
tesla's stock
nothing i just appreciate innovation
when i see it
and it is running the table with the
haters
ready yep okay
agricultural department workers wearing
protective suits
have eradicated the first nest of giant
murder hornets
discovered in the united states vacuum
vacuuming
them out of a tree in washington state
what why are you looking at me do you
think the murder hornets call the humans
murder humans because they murdered the
murder hornets probably
but i mean just it's just very
interesting to me that we call them
murder hornets as we
murder them well they apparently these
people spent weeks searching for the
nest
trapping the hornets and tracking them
using dental floss
to tie tiny radio trackers on the
insects which are nearly
two inches in length and have a painful
thing
i feel like instead of videos on them
that's like some science stuff like that
you know that's pretty crazy uh i mean
look if you come to
our country and you want to murder
people you can get vacuumed up
yeah we're going to vacuum you that's
fine
i mean and by the way i think that
actually the murder hornets i was
reading that
they're not nearly as deadly as murder
hornet would make it sound like if they
sting you then you immediately die
but uh
yeah but they definitely have some
issues you do not want to get stung by a
murder hornet
murder horner don't want to try to come
near me get the vacuum
i don't need a vacuum i just punch it in
the air punch in his little bug head
okay what's next um
what the next is a joke
what do you call a french guy wearing
sandals
a french guy wearing sandals yeah roman
no but that would have been kind of
funny um
philippe fellope
oh too funny okay all right
the great silence is upon us um
what else because you're not here i'm
not gonna say anything
that was a great joke good job yeah i
appreciate it
all right guys that's it for lunch money
we'll see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money
as much as we did and don't forget lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends